[MUSIC]
Director's Consortium is an executive
program for directors of public companies
or people who serve on boards
that are likely to go public.
This program emerged as a collaboration
between the business school and
the law school.
Drawing on both the expertise that our
faculty have around the many facets
of being successful in business.
And the legal foundation of the role of a
director and their legal responsibilities.
>> I bought probably 50
companies have been bought,
myself 10 times pretty much
thought I knew everything.
And then going through the process and
realized, well, I don't know everything,
just seeing how other directors
deal with similar situations.
>> As board directors, you get yourself
in big trouble when you stop learning and
when you start thinking
that you know a lot.
You do, but you don't know it all.
>> There are two distinctive features
to the Directors Consortium.
The classroom setting which allows for
intensive interaction among
the faculty and the participants.
And the second is the grounding
of the program and
research which provides
directors with frameworks and
evidence to address the questions
that they face in the boardroom.
>> The faculty here is very engaging.
They teach in a manner that you are not
just thinking about what they are teaching
but also reflecting upon your experiences.
They have a way to elicit conversation.
>> We've tried to keep the cohort small,
because we expect that the learning
doesn't happen only from the experts and
them sharing what they're
seeing on the research front.
But also in a collaborative fashion.
>> This provides a good forum for
us to kind of let our hair down and say,
this is my situation,
that's your situation.
>> All perspectives come
together to give each participant
a really rich understanding
of the new ones.
>> The content aims to provide
fundamentals and foundations, but also to
keep the board members abreast of all of
the emerging issues facing corporations.
Cutting edge issues like cybersecurity,
challenges facing the audit committee,
how to manage risk, how an official and
intelligence is going to play a role.
And what that means for directors and
the boards they serve on.
>> The option modules relate to
basic principles of accounting and
basic principles of finance.
This is for board members who might
feel rusty about these topics,
as well as board members who might not
be as well versed with these topics.
>> These are rules of thumb.
These are tool kits that will
be applicable not just today but
years from today and
they apply across every board.
>> I'm going to go by with lots of
ideas for best practices of how we can
run the board by even being in veteran
leader myself and my current job.
>> Without a doubt it was worth coming.
Without a doubt I've enhanced
my skill set, my being good.
>> When I think about the boards that I
sit on and what I brought to those boards
before this course, and what I will
bring to the boards after this course,
really shows that there
is a lot to be learned.